faire découvrir le patrimoine des
yvelines tout en s'amusant c'est le
concept de la société familiale créée à
club games
depuis le 1er novembre une nouvelle
édition yvelinoise de cire sino le
chasseur de trésor est disponible en
vente dans les magasins du département
thouaré guyancourt trappe ou encore
château ce sont 36 communes sur 262 qui
ont été retenus pour ce jeu on a demandé
au conseil départemental de choisir 12
ou grosses agglomérations 12 moyennes et
12 petits villages de manière à ce que
voilà chacun puisse identifier
ce matin là les créateurs de cire si
nous ont fait découvrir leurs jeux aux
enfants du centre aéré de maisons
laffitte
c'est un peu difficile de trouver à
l'épreuve et ben m.ban casitas style de
retourner au monde
ce jeu de société et au prix de 24 euros
95 et se joue de deux à quatre joueurs
sur chinois pour vocation d'être une
chasse au trésor dans le département
mais sans questions sans connaissance
particulière sans compétence
particulière
l'idée c'est vraiment de découvrir en
s'amusant et des six ans mais aussi de
faire plaisir à mamie donc d'être un jeu
intergénérationnel
le principe chaque commune à une carte
individuelle sur celle ci se trouve un
petit élément
cet élément est également sous forme de
pièces d'or cachés dans des coffres le
but
retrouvez ces pièces le plus vite
possible pour gagner la partie par
toujours du principe que le dernier de
la classe unique est en difficulté à
l'école doit pouvoir battre le premier
de la classe
parce que jouer ça à un moment où on lui
doit doit pas être en échec la société
kraken games est en train d'élaborer un
nouveau jeu de société sur le patrimoine
de la france qui sortira pour noël 2021